amber heard started only fans did you  see that did you really no  what do you think about uh the verdict  well i think it was probably um good for  all people who believe in the truth and  the problem is there's like this boys  versus girls narrative that i think we  all get into on these things a lot of  guys who wanted a guy to win one of  these things but it's just not good to  not be honest if you're doing that and  you're doing it to try to hurt someone  like if you're purposely changing  reality you're lying about what happened  just to try to hurt somebody you're  doing a [ __ ] up thing because you're  pretending you're a victim you're  turning someone into a criminal you're  pretending you're a victim and it's if  it's all not true it's a really bad  thing yeah it's really bad it's just bad  for all of us yeah it's just not good to  do [ __ ] like that  [Music]